Shure: 怎么了
Shure: 又怎么了
Nicous: 刚洗澡时候搁这
Nicous: 直接把把把衣服全把上衣全脱了
Nicous: 然后裸体了啊
Nicous: 就出现了这个
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: 不是你怎么敢在这就把衣服全脱了呢
Shure: 你就不怕他们仨突然出来吗
Nicous: 我脱了直接进里面洗头了
Nicous: 我弹那个弹那个
Nicous: 啵啵啵啵
Nicous: 啵啵
Nicous: 嘟嘟嘟
Shure: 家人们醒一醒啦
Shure: 醒醒
Jake:怎么一点用都没有呢
Shure: 不知道啊
Jake:是没有一点用吗
Jake:有用吗修硕
Shure: 是的没有用啊
Shure: Yeah, it’s useless.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 他睡得很死
Shure: He’s sleeping like a log.
Jake:他醒着的对吧
Jake: He’s awake, right?
Nicous: 给别人弹琴行不行
Nicous: How about playing the piano for others?
Nicous: 我们又没事
Nicous: We’ve got nothing to do anyway.
Jake:哈哈哈加油加油加油
Jake: Hahaha, come on, keep going!
Shure: 雨轩雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan, Yuxuan
Jake:打游戏了
Jake: He’s playing games.
Jake:我估计插耳机
Jake: I bet he’s got his headphones on.
Nicous: ok ok过一会要过来集合ok
Nicous: Ok, ok, we need to gather up in a bit, alright?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 估计是吧
Shure: Probably, yeah.
Jake:把菜质量这么好了
Jake: The food quality has gotten so good.
Jake:你醒了
Jake: You’re awake.
Jake:敲不醒
Jake: Can’t wake him up.
Nicous: 主要敲不醒一点
Nicous: Yeah, can’t wake him up at all.
Jake:他醒了以前都是他醒不了
Jake: He’s awake now, he usually can’t wake up.
Jake:每人都有醒不了的时刻
Jake: Everyone has moments where they can’t wake up.
Katrina: 你刚洗了吗
Katrina: Did you just wash up?
Shure: 有一点
Shure: A little.
Jake:有一点有点粉
Jake: A little, a bit pink.
Shure: 有点紫
Shure: Kind of purple.
Jake:有一种这个粉色的感觉
Jake: It has a pinkish feel to it.
Katrina: 这这这是确实粉紫色的
Katrina: Yeah, it’s definitely pinkish purple.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure: 雨轩现在要不帮忙叫一下吧
Shure: Yuxuan, maybe you can help call.
Jake:感觉到了
Jake: I can feel it.
Shure: 帮忙叫一下
Shure: Help call out.
Shure: 都鸭嗓子了
Shure: My voice is hoarse.
Jake:来两位帮忙帮个忙吧
Jake: Hey, you two, could you help out?
Katrina: 染吧染个那种骚骚粉
Katrina: Dye it that flashy pink.
Shure: 你要不私闯进去
Shure: Why don't you barge in?
Jake:弹了给个背景音
Jake: Play it, give some background music.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh my!
Katrina: 不在
Katrina: Not here.
Jake:不在
Jake: Not here.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:哎呀哎呀
Jake: Oh no, oh no.
Katrina: 瞎吧
Katrina: Blind?
Shure: 我寻思得睡多死啊
Shure: I thought they’d be deep asleep.
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死
Katrina: Haha, that's hilarious.
Katrina: 我的心
Katrina: My heart.
Jake:在还是不在啊
Jake: Are they here or not?
Katrina: 不在啊
Katrina: Not here.
Jake:不不在啊
Jake: No, not here.
Katrina: 床上没有人啊
Katrina: No one on the bed.
Jake:啊
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 那她去哪了
Shure: Where did she go?
Jake:问问
Jake: Ask around.
Katrina: 偶买噶增加一点悬疑的情节唉
Katrina: Oh my god, adding a bit of suspense!
Jake:这剧本挺好啊
Jake: This script is pretty good.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:是在这吗
Jake: Is it here?
Jake:是在厕所吗
Jake: In the bathroom?
Jake:会吗
Jake: Could it be?
Jake:那应该得听见是吧
Jake: We should be able to hear it, right?
Jake:头疼
Jake: Headache.
Katrina: 哈哈这一唱太有性缩力了
Katrina: Haha, this singing is so sexy.
Shure: 性缩力是什么意思
Shure: What does contraction tension mean?
Katrina: 性张力的反义
Katrina: It's the opposite of expansion tension.
Katrina: 不见了吗露亚
Katrina: Did Lucia disappear?
Jake:他去卫生所了
Jake: She went to the clinic.
Jake:他呃去玩狗的时候被狗抓了一下
Jake: She, uh, got scratched by a dog while playing with it.
Jake:他不放心
Jake: She was worried.
Jake:打疫苗去了
Jake: Went to get vaccinated.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:白敲啦
Jake: It's a wasted effort.
Katrina: 去哪打了呀
Katrina: Where did she get it?
Alice:去哪打了呀
Alice: Where did she get it?
Jake:就附近的一个卫生所
Jake: Just a nearby clinic.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:不用了
Jake: No need.
Shure: 加了我食指中间
Shure: Added it to my index finger.
Katrina: OK啊开始吧
Katrina: OK, let's start.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:唉还有一个人没选会没出来了
Jake: Hey, there's still one person who hasn't chosen.
Shure: Natasha
Shure: Natasha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 乌日啦mother rush
Shure: Urilaa mother rush.
Shure: i need you
Shure: I need you.
Katrina: 感觉骂的很脏
Katrina: Sounds really dirty.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: ralish
Shure: Relish.
Shure: 好的傻
Shure: Alright, silly.
Katrina: 越来越抽象了
Katrina: It's getting more abstract.
Jake:抽象确实抽象
Jake: Yeah, definitely abstract.
Katrina: 我那个香薰还蛮香的
Katrina: My aromatherapy smells pretty good.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure: 我让他给我占个位置
Shure: I asked him to save me a spot.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 呀
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 嗯嗯嗯
Shure: Mmm, mmm, mmm.
Shure: 哎我是不是把iPad拿外面了
Shure: Hey, did I leave my iPad outside?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 拿回来了吗
Shure: Did you bring it back?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Shure: 有哎外面好冷啊卧槽
Shure: Yeah, it's really cold outside, damn.
Jake:嚯短袖短裤
Jake: Whoa, short sleeves and shorts.
Alice:塔莎
Alice: Tasha.
Shure: 塔莎 早上好
Shure: Tasha, good morning.
Shure: 乌日朗
Shure: Uruzang.
Alice:早上好
Alice: Good morning.
Shure: 你没有听过二手玫瑰吗
Shure: Haven't you heard of Second Hand Rose?
Katrina: 跟谁说话呢
Katrina: Who are you talking to?
Shure: 跟你啊
Shure: Talking to you.
Katrina: 应该听过吧
Katrina: I think I've heard of them.
Katrina: 哎呦吆死
Katrina: Oh, ouch.
Alice:二手玫瑰哎
Alice: Second Hand Rose, huh.
Jake:唉  门开了
Jake: Hey, the door's open.
Shure: 门开了
Shure: The door's open.
Jake:但是
Jake: But...
Shure: 但是什么
Shure: But what?
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where's the person?
Shure: 但
Shure: But...
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 这首歌叫啥呀
Shure: What's this song called?
Katrina: 流沙
Katrina: Quicksand.
Shure: 哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Shure: 谜底写在谜面上了是吗
Shure: The answer is in the question, right?
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure: 哎我还
Shure: Hey, I also...
Shure: 我好像还会唱那个
Shure: I think I can sing that one too.
Katrina: 定一下歌呗
Katrina: Pick a song then.
Katrina: 如果要唱歌
Katrina: If you want to sing.
Katrina: 你是主力
Katrina: You're the lead.
Alice:能不能来一个听了之后不困的歌
Alice: Can we have a song that won't make us sleepy?
Katrina: 嗨一点的
Katrina: Something upbeat.
Katrina: 私奔
Katrina: Elopement.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 但我不太会唱啊
Katrina: But I don't know it well.
Katrina: 我上次去成都
Katrina: Last time I went to Chengdu.
Katrina: 感觉被咬的还是很痒那种
Katrina: I felt really itchy from the bites.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Shure: 啊里嘎多
Shure: Arigato.
Shure: 我上次去跟我女朋友去海边的时候
Shure: Last time I went to the beach with my girlfriend.
Shure: 拿着吉他
Shure: With a guitar.
Shure: 然后在海边就坐沙滩上唱的私奔
Shure: And we sat on the beach and sang "Elopement."
Katrina: 又来刺激我是吧
Katrina: You're trying to provoke me again, huh?
Katrina: 你要知道
Katrina: You need to know
Katrina: 晚上的我跟白天的我不是同一个人
Katrina: The nighttime me and the daytime me are not the same person.
Katrina: 斯班当时他们乐队有唱
Katrina: The band Spand sang back then
Katrina: 但是我不太会唱
Katrina: But I can't really sing it.
Shure: 很简单
Shure: It's really simple.
Katrina: 没插音箱吧怎么这么大声音
Katrina: Didn't plug in the amp, how come it's so loud?
Katrina: 唉 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Katrina: Oh, dun dun dun dun dun dun
Tasha:今天是在这偷的是吧
Tasha: Stealing here today, huh?
Jake:对外边冷了
Jake: Yeah, it's cold outside.
Shure: 唱不下去太高了
Shure: Can't sing it, it's too high.
Shure: 我们可以唱一点简单
Shure: We can sing something simpler.
Shure: 你们有听过朴树的new boy吗
Shure: Have you guys heard Pu Shu's "New Boy"?
Shure: 就是这一首
Shure: It's this one.
Jake:这朴树的
Jake: This is by Pu Shu.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 我也不知道
Katrina: I don't know either.
Shure: 这哥岁数比咱都大
Shure: This guy's older than all of us.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Shure: 回你了还是你回他了
Shure: Did you reply to him or did he reply to you?
Katrina: 另一个
Katrina: The other one.
Shure: 另一个
Shure: The other one.
Shure: 咦什么人
Shure: Who's that?
Jake:你看见过
Jake: Have you seen it?
Shure: 让我暖洋洋
Shure: Makes me feel warm.
Katrina: 一下可以叫醒三个
Katrina: Can wake up three at once.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 我直接开始国际歌起来
Shure: I'll start with the Internationale.
Jake:国际歌用吉他合适合不合适
Jake: Is it suitable to play the Internationale with a guitar?
Shure: 合适
Shure: Suitable.
修硕能:能唱我们我们
Shure: We can sing it.
Shure: 主要是看我们能不能唱
Shure: The main thing is whether we can sing it.
Jake:能唱能唱
Jake: We can sing it.
Jake:国际歌怎么了
Jake: What's wrong with the Internationale?
Jake:你又没唱
Jake: You didn't sing it.
Jake:算了呵
Jake: Forget it, haha.
Shure: 呵我知道你想说什么
Shure: Haha, I know what you want to say.
Shure: 杨老板你很危险
Shure: Jake, you're dangerous.
Jake:你不知道
Jake: You have no idea.
Shure: 我真不知道吗
Shure: Do I really have no idea?
Jake:你知道
Jake: You know...
Shure: 我该不该知道呢
Shure: Should I know?
Katrina: 唱
Katrina: Sing.
Shure: 唱什么国际歌吗
Shure: Sing what, the International?
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 我找一张谱子
Shure: I'll find a sheet.
Katrina: 所以我们在等待什么
Katrina: So what are we waiting for?
Shure: 我在等待
Shure: I'm waiting...
Shure: 塔莎戴眼镜
Shure: For Tasha to put on her glasses.
Shure: 起来  哎呀
Shure: Get up, oh man...
Jake:他哪去了
Jake: Where did he go?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha...
Katrina: 你以后跟我说
Katrina: Next time, tell me...
Katrina: 要带一个那个GPS模块了
Katrina: We need to bring a GPS module.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:人均
Jake: Everyone.
Katrina: 哈哈哈人均丢失一次
Katrina: Hahaha, everyone gets lost once.
Jake:我刚刚想说一个人的名字
Jake: I was just about to mention someone's name...
Jake:但是不敢说
Jake: But I didn't dare.
Jake:算了
Jake: Never mind.
Shure: 不对这个谱子有问题
Shure: No, this sheet music is wrong.
Shure: 在臭美什么    咦
Shure: What are you showing off... Eww...
Katrina: 自拍一下
Katrina: Just taking a selfie.
Shure: 给那个人发是吧好好好
Shure: Sending it to that person, right? Okay, okay.
Katrina: 不是不是
Katrina: No, no.
Shure: 不是 啊 不是 啊
Shure: No? Ah, no? Ah...
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 不是
Katrina: No.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ahhhh...
Shure: 嗯嗯嗯嗯
Shure: Mmm mmm mmm mmm...
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 好听
Katrina: Sounds good.
Shure: 好听
Shure: Sounds good.
Shure: 让我再看你一眼
Shure: Let me look at you again.
Shure: 从南到北
Shure: From south to north.
Shure: 没没没没没
Shure: No, no, no, no, no...
Shure: 你看过那个吗
Shure: Have you seen that?
Shure: 羊头版的那个
Shure: The one with the sheep's head.
Shure: 安和桥
Shure: Anhe Bridge.
Shure: new boy
Shure: New boy.
Katrina: 哎new boy
Katrina: Hey, new boy.
Katrina: 哦那就唱这个呗
Katrina: Oh, let's sing this one then.
Shure: 他他
Shure: He, he...
Shure: 这个歌还有一个同样调的另一个版本
Shure: This song has another version with the same tune.
Shure: 叫什么
Shure: What's it called?
Shure: 曾曾经怎么说
Shure: It was... How do you say it?
Shure: 唉我草我忘了
Shure: Ah, damn, I forgot.
Katrina: AI在注视你
Katrina: The AI is watching you.
Shure: 等一下啊
Shure: Wait a second.
Shure: 哦叫forever young
Shure: Oh, it's called "Forever Young."
Shure: 就是一样的调
Shure: It's the same tune.
Shure: 但是它的词儿不一样那个是
Shure: But the lyrics are different, that one is...
Katrina: 你在揉面
Katrina: Are you kneading dough?
Jake:对你们把曲子定了吧
Jake: Yeah, you guys decide on the song.
Jake:你们仨把曲子定了吧
Jake: You three decide on the song.
Katrina: 所以说我把开会流程变成我们三个了
Katrina: So, the meeting process is just the three of us now.
Jake:我把这
Jake: I'll...
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 然后就是把曲子定一下就好
Shure: So, just settle on the song, that's all.
Jake:曲子定一下
Jake: Decide on the song.
Katrina: 谁会唱歌
Katrina: Who can sing?
Jake:明天明天安排
Jake: We'll arrange it for tomorrow.
Katrina: 柯欣你唱吗
Katrina: Ke Xin, will you sing?
Jake:明明天明天探探走一遍明
Jake: Tomorrow, we'll go over it once.
Katrina: 咱搞一个合唱呗就不跳舞了
Katrina: Let's do a chorus, no dancing.
Jake:对明天探探和
Jake: Yeah, tomorrow we'll go over it.
Jake:就是其实明天就是彩排
Jake: Actually, tomorrow is just a rehearsal.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:和收视方面
Jake: And checking the viewership.
Katrina: 唱呗不然就我们两个
Katrina: Let's sing, otherwise it'll just be the two of us.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 我们俩唱
Shure: We'll sing.
Katrina: 多尴尬啊
Katrina: How awkward.
Shure: 唱素颜 哈哈哈
Shure: Let's sing "Plain."
Katrina: 我们两个直接唱破音
Katrina: The two of us will just sing off-key.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:唱对
Jake: Sing, yeah.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: It's okay.
Katrina: 哎素颜很适合
Katrina: "Plain" is very suitable.
Katrina: 吉他那个耶
Katrina: With the guitar, yeah.
Shure: 好像是
Shure: Seems like it.
Jake:那你们聊聊
Jake: You guys chat.
Jake:然后彩排也聊一聊
Jake: And also chat during the rehearsal.
Katrina: 搞个节目
Katrina: Let's do a show.
Katrina: 我感觉唱歌比唱歌可以唱个俩
Katrina: I feel like singing, maybe we can sing two songs.
Jake:我我们揉完应该就上来了
Jake: We should be up after we finish the practice.
Jake:也揉个20分钟吧
Jake: Let's practice for 20 minutes.
Katrina: 唱个大家都会的国歌
Katrina: Let's sing a national anthem that everyone knows.
Shure: 你你怎么这么疯呢
Shure: Why are you so crazy?
Katrina: 我我是火象星座
Katrina: I am a fire sign.
Shure: 你火象星座你也不会违
Shure: Even if you are a fire sign, you can't break the law.